Well, for one thing, the creation of the object and adding
a loc property seems like something we could do up in the Car constructor.
Where we used to have object creation, we can simply call the Car function now
and it'll produce an object that can act as the starting point for
the rest of the subclass.
Technically, we have a working superclass at this point, but
there's still more repeated code that we should be able to move into it.
Let's take the code for the addition of a move method out of
those subclass constructors and move it up here into the superclass constructor.
At this point, we have two complete subclass functions and
one superclass constructor function that creates a bit of a starting point for
each of those subclasses to build on top of.